c'est officiel les fidèles skids mgen
passeront par trappe le 1er juin
prochain
c'est la deuxième fois que ces journées
de la forme sont organisées dans cette
ville où environ 500 enfants de 5 à 12
ans pourront participer au tri à tous on
va faire un triathlon sur des distances
adaptées à l'âge des enfants
un triathlon d'initiation on va faire 20
m de natation dans une piscine que nous
installerons le matin même on partira
sur le parking de la mairie sur des
boucles pour arriver à réaliser un
kilomètre de vélo puis après avoir posé
le vélo on part en course à pied la
troisième discipline du triathlon
jusqu'à passer la ligne d'arrivée sur le
parking bas à côté de l'amérique en plus
d'un village éphémère pour s'amuser et
découvrir les droits de l'enfant de
nombreux ateliers pour inculquer des
valeurs citoyennes seront organisées
même si l'objectif principal du fidesz
qu'ils restent de démocratiser la
discipline du triathlon auprès des plus
jeunes
la plus belle phrase que j'ai entendu à
propos des fields mgen c'est apprendre
aux enfants à vivre demain
apprendre aux enfants à vivre ensemble à
faire du sport ensemble à trier leurs
déchets à préserver leur environnement à
accepter les différences avec les autres
tous ces ateliers qui vont permettre
pendant à peu près une heure et demie de
délivrer un message aux enfants des
messages de citoyenneté et de bien-être
toujours à partir des sports les fit et
ce qu'ils restent une initiation
ici pas de compétition de classement
l'important est de participer
il pourrait qu'on pense à chaque étape
un tirage au sort aura lieu pour emmener
les gagnants à la finale nationale le 12
juillet prochain à castellane